TRYING TO BE TRANSPARENT AND
HONEST TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
WILLIAM DOUGLAS CAMPBELL IS THE
URANIUM ONE INFORMANT.
TO PROTECT HIS IDENTITY WE PUT
HIM IN SHADOW.
WELCOME TO THE PROGRAM.
YOU WORKED AS AN OPERATIVE FOR
MULTIPLE AGENCIES HOW MANY
YEARS?
>> 30 YEARS.
>> Sean: AND YOU FIRST GOT
INVOLVED WITHIN A PUTIN AND
RUSSIAN OPERATION WITHIN THE
UNITED STATES IN 2009, CORRECT?
>> ACTUALLY EARLIER THAN THAT.
MY WORKED HANDED OVER TO THE FBI
STARTED IN FBI.
I WAS UNDER FORMAL CONTRACT AND
AN ASSOCIATE PARTNER WITH THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT AND ITS
SENIOR RUSSIAN NUCLEAR
RELATIONSHIP THAT WORKED WITH
PUTIN.
>> Sean: 30 YEARS YOU SERVED
YOUR COUNTRY IN DANGEROUS
SITUATIONS AT TIMES?
>> YES, SIR, YOU COULD SAY THAT.
>> Sean: LIFE THREATENING?
>> YOU COULD SAY THAT.
>> Sean: AT SOME POINT,
MR. CAMPBELL, YOUR LIFE IS AT
RISK.
YOU SEE RUSSIANS INFILTRATE THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
LIVING WITHIN AMERICA.
YOU BECAME AWARE THAT RUSSIA
WANTED TO GET A FOOTHOLD IN THE
URANIUM INDUSTRY AND WERE
LOOKING AT URANIUM ONE.
THAT DEAL WAS GOING TO GIVE THEM
THAT FOOTHOLD IF IT WAS APPROVED
BY 9 GOVERNMENT AGENCIES?
>> YES, SIR.
THERE WAS NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
>> Sean: THE FBI KNEW IT?
>> THE BUREAU KNEW IT.
THE URANIUM ONE POSITION WAS A
PART OF A LONG-TERM STRATEGY BY
THE RUSSIANS.
>> Sean: DID THESE RUSSIAN
CRIMINAL
CRIMINA
CRIMINALS.
HILLARY CLINTON IS SECRETARY OF
STATE AND BARACK OBAMA IS THE
PRESIDENT.
DID THEY EXPRESS ANY SPECIFIC
CLINTON STRATEGY TO GET HER ON
BOARD OR ANY OBAMA STRATEGY?
>> THIS WAS A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION OF PEOPLE I HAD
REPORTED.
YES, THE RUSSIANS AND THE UNITED
STATES CONSPIRATORS STATED THE
CLINTONS WERE IMPLICATED.
THAT WAS NOT THE FOCUS OF WHAT I
WAS DOING.
I DIDN'T BELIEVE UNTIL THE
URANIUM ONE APPROVAL ACTUALLY
HAPPENED THAT THE INDICATIONS
FROM THESE RUSSIANS WERE SOLID
ABOUT THE CLINTSONS INFLUENCE
ABOUT THE CLINTSONS INFLUENIN
ABOUT THE CLINTSONS INFLUENING
THAT DECISION.
>> Sean: DID THEY HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT CLINTON WOULD
SIGN OFF ON THIS DEAL?
>> ABSOLUTELY CONFIDENCE.
>> Sean: CONFIDENCE THAT OBAMA
WOULD SIGN OFF ON THIS DEAL?
>> THEY WERE QUITE SURE THAT
OBAMA AND THE ADMINISTRATION
WHOM THEY HAD DEEMED AND LABELED
AS BEING VERY WEAK MULTIPLE
TIMES WOULD RESPOND FAVORABLY.
>> Sean: ARE A PATRIOTIC
AMERICAN AND YOU ARE RISKING
YOUR LIFE.
HEARING THAT THE COUNTRY AND THE
PRESIDENT IS SECRETARY OF STATE
ARE WEAK, I WOULD FEEL BAD FOR
MY COUNTRY.
>> I REACTED TO IT AND
CHALLENGED MY FBI HANDLER AS TO
WHY THE HELL ALL OF THE WORK
DONE MONITORING THE SUCCESSFUL
RUSSIAN STRATEGY I REPORTED
SINCE 2006 HAD FALLEN BY THE WAY
SIDE AND APPROVAL WAS ALLOWED TO
PROCEED.
>> Sean: WHAT WAS THE POSSIBLE
EXPLANATION?
I CAN'T EXPECT ANY REASONABLE
EXPLANATION WHY WE WOULD HAND
OVER URANIUM WHEN WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH?
>> THEY WERE ACCOUNTABLE TO
ROBERT MUELLER.
>> Sean: THE FBI DIRECTOR.
>> WHO WAS OVERSEEING MY
OPERATION.
LOOKED AT ME AND CONVEYED TO ME
FRUSTRATION AND SAID, ASK YOUR
POLITICS.
>> Sean: IT TAKES MY BREATH
AWAY.
THIS IS AN EPIC, THE MOST
SPECTACULAR FAILURE.
CAN YOU CONCLUDE, WHAT IS THE
POSSIBLE MOTIVATION FOR PEOPLE
NOT TO DO THEIR JOB AT THIS HIGH
LEVEL?
THIS IS KEY TO AMERICA'S
NATIONAL SECURITY?
>> IT WAS POLITICAL AND THEY
BELIEVED THAT HILLARY CLINTON
WOULD BE ELECTED PRESIDENT.
THEY WERE GUN-SHY.
THEY WERE POLITICAL.
AND THEY TURNED THEIR BACK ON
THE COUNTRY IN MY OPINION.
>> Sean: THANKS FOR TELLING US